Speaker 1: right after Trump was arrested.
Trump got directly into a vehicle and went
straight to the airport and flew back to Florida.
His attorneys held a sort of very strange
press conference right outside the courthouse.
This is Joe Tacopina, as well as Trump's other
lawyer whose name escapes me at this exact
moment in time.
But we will find it.
It didn't go very well.
It was just a complete and total mess.
The only thing missing was holding it at four
seasons, total landscaping or whatever it
was called, Four Seasons Landscaping.
But let's take a listen to a little bit of
this.
Speaker 4: They did not use language.
He requested that everybody in law refrain
from using language.
It's inappropriate, by the way.
That includes that includes the witnesses,
the witnesses for the people who are talking,
just.
Speaker 5: As the former president swinging
a baseball bat at the head of the Manhattan
D.A..
Speaker 4: I don't know where you got that
because it was a tweet that was out by the
fact that, you know, it was first of all,
first of all, first of all, that picture was
not swinging a baseball bat.
I mean, if you want to distort the facts,
go right ahead.
I won't address that.
Yes, it is.
If you want to swing a baseball bat at anyone's
head.
That was a picture of him showing off an American
made that.
Speaker 1: He was talking about how great
American bat.
Yeah.
I mean, it's certainly a compilation picture.
So Tacopina is right that the picture was
was isolated.
It was two different pictures put together.
But Trump did posted the truth central.
And we've got the picture up on the screen.
It's a picture of Melvyn Bragg side by side
with Trump holding a bat.
Obviously, he wasn't actually holding a bat
to Alvin Black's head, but Trump did post
that to truth social.
Let's look at another little bit of that discussion.
Speaker 4: There was no I want to stress that
the president can't use language that would
incite violence or civil unrest.
He did not request that the president not
use language.
He requested that everybody in train from
using language is inappropriate, by the way,
that includes that includes the witnesses.
The witnesses for the people who are talking,
just.
Speaker 5: Includes the former president swinging
a baseball bat at the head of the Manhattan.
Speaker 4: D.A..
Well, I don't know where you got that because
it was a tweet that was you know, it was first
of all, first of all, first of all, that picture
was not swinging a baseball bat.
I mean, if you want to distort the facts,
go right ahead.
I want to address that.
Yes, it is.
If you want to swing a baseball bat at anyone's
head, that was a picture of him showing off
an American made bat.
Someone else put a picture of the district
attorney next to him.
And in an article posted that that's not he's.
Speaker 5: Not using language that incites.
Speaker 4: Guys, Here's what we're talking
about today.
Here's what we're going to talk about, the
insufficiency of this case.
And I will say this to you.
Today's unsealing of this indictment shows
that the rule of law died in this country.
Speaker 1: Did it really?
No.
Actually, the indictment shows that no one
is above the law and they keep insisting that
this means the rule of law of law died.
No.
What we've learned is not even a former president
is above the law.
And that's a great thing to learn.
Speaker 4: While everyone is not above the
law, no one's below it either.
And if this man's name was not Donald J. Trump,
there is no scenario we'd all be here today.
Please understand that based on these charges.
Speaker 1: All right.
So there's TACOPINA and then we have, I guess,
one more clip here about Trump's posts about
the judge and the judge's family.
Speaker 4: We are here to talk about the case
a little bit.
This we can't address what he post or what
he wants to post it.
But as his attorneys, have you told to stop
posting this?
So why is it that we can't list literally,
we can't tell you what we've discussed?
No, I'm so sorry that you mean continuing
to go after the judge, talking about the judge's
wife, talking about the family?
I mean, are you.
I mean, I don't think he was concerned about
it.
Yeah, but any other defendant, wouldn't you
be like, I know you're going.
Speaker 5: After the judge.
He is not going after the judge.
He commented that he thought that there were
some issues that may cause a conflict that's
not going after the judge who is not threatening
the judge.
He is not going after the Judge Stone after
he has said that.
Speaker 1: You may also notice that someone's
holding the leg of a mannequin over the head
of Attorney Joe Tacopina during this entire
thing.
That's an important visual component.
Speaker 5: Yeah, he is angry because the D.A.
has brought a case that is unjustified.
And so I'm not going to comment on it.
You may disagree with the way he spoke.
Speaker 4: The process was you fingerprinted,
was 010.
Speaker 5: Thank you for your attention.
Speaker 1: All right.
So the deciding that this was not going particularly
well for them and then wrapping it up, a wild
day in lower Manhattan.
Let's take a very quick break.
Next, we will talk about the event that took
place.
At Mar a Lago.
We're going to hear from Lindsey Graham.
There's so much more.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE was run out of Manhattan
trying to protest.
It was one of the craziest day in American
politics in a long time.
We will be back right after this and give
you the rest of the day's news.